i read that there was a 11 year old girl
who um
there was an 11 year old girl who was on
holiday in italy yeah sitting in a hot
spring this massive hot spring in italy
yeah and just from sitting in the water
she caught gonorrhea
she caught
gonorrhea
no she never because the water
is like it says on there like
according to the nhs standards
you can't catch an sti from just water
but
though apparently these things is body
temperature like the water
pretty much remains at body temperature
or if not a little bit warmer like
forever so it's perfectly possible that
if someone we've gonorrhea was in that
water that they could transmit to the
girl that was just there 11 year old 11
year old bro so apparently she just had
symptoms
yo
symptoms so apparently she had symptoms
they gave her like some anti-fungal
cream just for his little piece of
thrush or something a few days later she
was like nah fam like this is bothering
me mum like what's going on
took her to the hospital or to the
doctor
gave her a little swabby swab said fam
your daughter's got gonorrhea how do you
even
and they had to say big man have you
have you been
and she said nah like no i'm 11. i'm 11
big man fam i'm 11. and then obviously
they all believed her like nah like she
can't have she literally can't have and
then they said like it must have come
from the hot spring
as disgusting as that is the first thing
i thought was mandem i've got a claws
the man out there have finally got a
claws
because i've been hearing the sharing
tower business for years and no one
believes it yeah it's all hubbub yeah
there's there's there's no facts there
yeah but now there's facts bro it must
have been i was at the spa it was in the
spring yeah me and the boys were in the
in
in the sauna the other day
we had a little jacuzzi dip dip
chin wagon just a feather wagon
i heard through the grapevine that josh
has got a little something in it
i heard that i didn't think just
spending time with him in the pool was
going to do anything yeah but clearly
it's possible it's possible and clearly
that's what's happened man did you not
hear about what happened in italy the
hot spring thing the 11 year old she's
all over the news yeah bro it's a
pandemic at it
oh it's
we live violated
[Music]
anyway let's move on
let's let's scurry to the doctors and
get this let's get this over with yeah
together
i'll put the penicillin on your tongue
[Laughter]
that's when that's when
these times now jeremy carl will come
out of the hiding bro he's uncanceled
for that he'll be uncancelled he needs
to know
where this [ __ ] is coming from
because you're a liar
sometimes
his own source he did he did he was
swimming in his own source he tried so
hard not to to smile whilst he was on
set you could tell
prick fam he got gassed off himself he
loved bringing people up mm-hmm and then
just being like because you're a liar
you're a liar
don't but this is his favorite thing
this is jeremy carl
this is jeremy carr
so what you're telling me is
is that she seduced you she told you she
was
on contraception and now you feel
betrayed because she's has she's had
this child that you don't want anything
to do with you didn't ask for you can't
afford to pay child support everything
like that is that what you're telling me
i'm like yeah yeah that's what i'm
saying
you see this is what's wrong with the
world this is what's wrong with the
world ladies and gentlemen
why didn't you put something on the end
of it
and he waits for that applause he says
there like that
you should have put something on the end
of it yeah somebody here you're gonna
have something the end of it
he just mumbles his way forever she was
the end of it and this one bodyguard
just sits through
people run for germany
you better [ __ ] relax yourself cuz
wham bodyguard biggest
[ __ ] better relax yourself cuz
jeremy just gets up [ __ ] hard off he
can't touch he loved himself he loved
himself he loved cussing people out ah
jeremy cowell show man i'm sure
i'm sure we used to watch out helene
though was it jeremy carl used to watch
back a day in the little yeah in the
little community no recess room i'm sure
it was yeah we did young jezza [ __ ] you
now jeremy carl was there
tv 10 years ago 11 years ago jokes man
fam
the worst of england was on jeremy carr
the worst dreads of england do you
remember when he tried to go to america
that was so dead so he tried to run his
mouth in america sam they weren't having
any of it it was fake in america of
course they're scripted of course of
course why did americans always do that
why does everyone have in america have
to be fake
like he was getting views in the uk yeah
but he wanted that big order yeah he
wanted that big thing he did a young two
seasons they sent him packing yeah it
was terrible terrible but yeah that's
that's um
that's young just for you